you
stay focused go fishing go fishing is
the plan maybe all right Mike
give me that ticker Oh let's close out
of the cafe I almost want two steps
there all right we have some kind of a
French that's some kind of a French this
is the French all right let's let's card
III they can't be too excited about that
I'm gonna take there I still have
thoughts of h2 but not right away that's
so quick my bishop out rook c8 and then
something here pawn push I do this okay
I got that light square bishop let's
take this let's take that and get out of
the line of fire hit the Queen she can't
be comfortable throw a knight on a
central post get over here where do we
want to be could have taken that guy
should have smashed that guy right up
let's do it now right now my rook is
SuperDuper active there goes the bishop
pair I already have a flight square
double the rooks double trouble I don't
want a Queen trade can you believe it
I really need to take that night he's
gonna kill me
all right maybe I do want to Queen trade
get rid of that I should just take now
no no no no he's pinned though he's a
pinned piece don't take pin pieces well
I just made him pinned even on time give
me that pawn King position King position
let's trade now I should have given up
that net square oh oh oh hang on keep
everything nice and cozy my king is
gonna go pawn hunting get over here run
pawn run fast right here and that's me
back to tournament land
whoo four three two a lot of tubes okay
well I beat me to the punch there this
dude beat me to the punch but he's down
with quick resigner ah man was that a
mouse slip did you Mouse slip on that
resign button the plan is to decline the
Smith morrow my way and also to sniff
out this the Bill Gates square I really
don't mean any anything by that I don't
I don't wanna I'm not insulting Bill
Gates by saying that somebody said that
at a comment on YouTube you're not gonna
let that one go they said I really
didn't have a good reply I guess I guess
not
I guess that's me for my reply oh geez
I'm not gonna let it go it's just too
appealing right I could take this bishop
that's always nice each to their it is
wise just say why'd you say page two I
think they're I think they're trolling
me they're listening the stream they're
like alright I'll just let him have his
ways there's a lot of his waves on h2 if
that's gonna make him happy here we go
don't forget about h7 though h2 s
brother alright okay okay okay Queen c2
sniffing out h7 get the bishop on b7
yeah let's shut down okay let's change
of plans this is still a good structure
I'm gonna get in d4 let's roll with it
take with the pawn keep him here yeah
okay so we're gonna have a hanging pawn
structure I could throw my knight here
why not if takes then the D files opened
up I'm on the night and then d5 is gonna
fall most likely and it is here take
with the rook the knight is pinned to
this pawn I don't think can be capture
the Queen is gone just like that
design time design time back to
tournament 2029 bunch of sixes
master the master of the universe master
of the universe I just show my age a
little bit right there man masters of
the universe that's where it all started
I didn't even realize that come
queenside up hang on
change of plans I'm not gonna pond push
here where's that night going what a
sneaky guy pick up the bishop pair wow I
was really defending against age two
he's throwing the night there all right
well I got the bishop pair let's see
what I could do with it though dark
square bishop I love having the dark
square bishop because of this guy he is
now
knifing the white position with check
and I really feel like going in this
direction they resigned back to
tournament I was thinking about Knight
g4 there just to get the H file opened
up new one Seinfeld is this the Seinfeld
Newman no that's not the right spelling
but uh
Newman all right I'm looking for a space
gainer space invader move I got it I got
the space and let's resolve this pin
nobody likes being in a pin yeah let's
go here how is he gonna develop this
night is not the greatest piece in the
world right not here to maybe here whoa
this is this is like that 960 game that
was just played Kings making a mad dash
it's open stuff up that King is running
for his life
got a rook on the C file he's he's gonna
be caught in a crossfire soon isn't he
tricky Night Moves discovered attacks
against the Queen
it's got to be good on that Queen she's
gone right sneak in here where's the
mate happening soon checks here or here
to cover here or grab on eh I can't be
too bad the Knights in a pin
it's 200 I could have taken a ruck that
wouldn't be too bad
that's mate though smothered mate 42 are
close to it he had that a dd8 square but
my bishop was watching over it
c5 let's try the French why not okay
let's go with this Queen b6 Bishop d7
well it's not gonna happen so easily
Knight here I could take on f2 or went
upon Queen Esther block otherwise I get
that guy now the plan is pile up on this
guy and you can't be defended if Knight
if Knight here I was gonna play King to
e7 I'm up to pawns this isn't a threat
now since it's not coming with check
Knight no this Knights close to being
trapped he is trapped now my knight I
just move him if he's attacked to a safe
square let's take this pawn first I'm
threatening forts and stuff give me that
light square bishop and then I'll track
down that night however let's first
defend against g7 my Knights unprotected
here but that should be too big of a
deal this should net that night 22
minutes remaining in the tournament so
let's double Brooks and I'm gonna do
that by posting in White's territory as
I double alright still in White's
territory my rook is restricted a little
bit but so too is this and now I'm
smashing thrill where is the main they
resigned back determine 56 I've got
seven games in fairly well I have that
quick resigner so really just kind of
like that's six games really oh okay I
thought for a second that it wasn't
gonna start it's starting though c4
Knight c3 Queen c2 no move well if you
don't move it's gonna be an automatic
win you got like 15 seconds or something
to make that first move down ran out of
time
72 okay
here we go let's try what let's okay
well let's try something simple get my
minor pieces out
maybe preserve my bishop if I'm allowed
night here as a mill it's not gonna be
that I think I almost mouse slipped that
one let's let's attack a knight get my
queen here
there is no a3 back him up that's why I
did a six winning upon that it's just in
a pin the Knight captures I take here
and actually I'm up a full rook now
after all that let's take with the Queen
since it offers exchanges when I'm up
material hang on hang on hang on whoa
what's going let's just stop this bone
from moving all together I don't want to
let these guys have any thoughts of
stuff on g7 all right I can't I can't
maintain my Queen's position so let's do
that let's go here where's my time
that's a very good question I have a lot
I worked the forks so much material do
something with it what you do something
with it do something with the material
you have take this and then that take
this and then that
who could argue with that I better argue
with that variation take this and that
if I were you in this position I would
take this and then do that ninety forty
two thirty seven thirty less than twenty
minutes remaining
okay okay let's go here let's let's try
e4 for once instead of going like crazy
against the H 2 and H 7 squares just get
some pre moves in but that's ok it's not
be too quick so Pierce perk
um all right let's break that pin
it's Castle okay so now they're gonna
try and play a closed position and I'm
not wanting a closed position
let's open stuff up so get this pawn
rolling try and break down this point
and get my bishop here maybe I should
have done that first no I don't know
upon push I know it's coming no it's not
coming there pawn push was threatening
bishop here now it's giving up d5 let's
do this I want to stop knight here and I
get my bishop to this square bishop here
rookie to d1 is my plan very
sophisticated
that was probably unnecessary let's kick
that Queen out I want to do this move I
don't want to allow c4 so my Knights
gonna be coming back this pawn is
backwards I'm gonna pile up on it
one week pawn equates to maybe just one
really good plan for you in this case
it's gonna be to put pressure on this or
just even post up on this square why did
I do that let's watch over that let's
just throw my knight in there that's
where he wants to be take like this open
up the D file play here strike at this
pawn and this one now I don't want to
Queen trade taken I'm really tempted to
take on this square that bishop stuff to
remove this Queen has to be she's really
close to being trapped there's no way
she could live it's happening soon pawn
push bishop here I think she's toast
pawn push bishop here she's officially
out of squares they're down on time
though back determine 110 110 okay I'm
the pack leader there's um I'd rather
actually be catching somebody believe it
or not there's less stress less stress
involved if you're the one who's chasing
somebody that's stressed they're the one
who has to worry behind my heels that's
the question I could have grabbed that
pond
why didn't I then
let's just develop I could still grab it
now I can't grab that pond but it scares
me to be perfectly honest it definitely
scares me I'm gonna try it though oh no
it's really bad it's really bad because
of that move oh okay I gotta come up
with some sneaky stuff why didn't I do
that why did I do that
all right let's trade they're not gonna
trade though oh my goodness I gotta do
this I am a dead duck
yeah oh man am i dead I am so dead
can I get that now this is so dead it
really is it really is oh my goodness I
am gonna get hammered
I get so hurt here it comes I'm gonna
scream I'm definitely gonna scream yep
it's happening soon come on Knight do
something dangerous 9.2 seconds
let me taking that guy pac-man note I
could have given a check here maybe I
should have could I just get time
burners in I should be able to get time
burners defense stuff oh my rooks dead
the very least I take here I have a
tricky night though oh why did I do that
oh no I mean me I'm gonna get mated
that's me oh oh okay well what I'm I'm
down man
I lose that game was I getting too
confident there I saw a lead ah
Queen to age five that gonna crush me
that move crushed me this guy's not
moving though the bird is a girl maybe
the princess princess was not around to
play that game ah Queen the age
see the first time I don't go after h2
look what happens now everybody's gonna
play the French they see what's possible
he's gonna miss a queen h5 move play the
French defense okay let's get developed
and stay focused
let's recapture here let's kick the
night to the edge how bad can that be
really think about it how bad can that
move really be okay um let's get to this
square this is an isolated Queen palm
position my bishop belongs on c6 I'm
gonna grab that guy though let's grab
that guy I could grab here no it's not
like this is a bishop that can move and
give check its I'm threatened made on g2
it's gonna be missed
no I was almost ready to do that Knights
a freebie let's trade Queens really felt
like I could have somehow won that if I
didn't get mated you could say that
about any position I could have won that
if I didn't get mated that's true genius
statement of the year the queen is
hitting the bishop is hit pin City
coming up over here pigs who can argue
with the pig on the second-ranked
back determine 148 122 I gotta watch out
for this guy he's close to being in
striking distance hyper dragons is on
the scene I believe he knows all about
fishing pole land okay I have a space
gaining move and this bishop is now
biting on a rock it's castle if this
opens up this could be big big trouble I
think it's close to being big big
trouble I'm gonna pile up on that pinch
piece pawn push weakens this Square
immensely immensely why am I trying to
move my bishop like it's a knight I had
the right idea I wanted to get a piece
there yeah I should I should shoot down
there right away oh well why am I going
in Reverse here's a here's a fork okay
this is this is not this is not what I
planned for sure am I gonna make up my
mind let's go here first you
take that guy I kicked that night out of
this squared no trades that's the no
soup for you move right there all right
push not here to here hang on not so
fast it's still difficult because of
this space advantage believe it or not
it's still difficult or is it we're
gonna trade aren't we I don't want to
trade so much I'm down material uh-oh
hang on my night is really short on
squares let's do this
okay he's I got to do this or something
key position closed come over here the
Bishop's gonna give a check now I'm on
that I'm down on time oh no no no oh
come on go go go we're here grab a pond
for a second I thought um oh this is big
trouble
That's not me it is it on the bishop
that guy just push here Ron Pond you're
fast
you're really fast
always trying to pre-move trying to
promote man ah schemes are getting
tougher where's my time it's going
further further away I should have had
that ah now that guy's right back on my
heels right back on my heels oh okay
Knight g4 back to the same old baloney
h2 man if I didn't have that h2 square
would have nothing this guy's lead now
but I'm right on his heels how does he
like it maybe he's gonna get nervous
like I've been get nervous am I just
making up excuses Age 2 strikes again I
did have a little bit of a mouse issue
on that one that it could I blame it on
the Adobe Flash okay there's the creepy
crawler the creepy crawler defense quick
strike quick strike King takes hang on
back up that bishop I like my bishop too
much open the position up grab pieces
more pieces with check and then here no
matter what
this guy's throwing the whole farm at me
right the whole farm okay I don't even
know what that means
okay I'm in check oh they couldn't just
take my bishop all right yeah I think
there are given too much weight to
playing fast or um or what loyalist King
he's running he's running fast that's
trouble
check right here and then mate coming up
soon
Wow where's the main where is it where's
the mate it's not it okay one two three
no stalemate back to term in 212 I got
to catch that guy
186 he's he Wentz he's 69 16 this guy
I'll slam me if I'm not careful okay
here we go
I got a I got established upon in the
center I should have waited to take
there okay my knight right here that's
where he belongs
okay they they they waste and move there
take the knight and then look for me
look for meit right here Queen's there
to defend
let's check I'm on the rook they're
gonna resign oh they're gonna grab here
yes they are yeah I missed that one why
did I miss that one oh they're gonna
take here oh my goodness let's go back
um here turning a fork fork town oh my
goodness let's defend no I still had a
fork what are you doing I could give a
fork here - oh now they see it oh my
goodness hit a queen would you ah man I
had a fork and a half that would have
been beautiful 27 seconds each regroup
and stay focused okay I have a flight
square I have peace coordination run run
run run get to the seventh rank okay I'm
getting this tricky check man that would
have been so nice look at this triple
palm formation let's not do that here I
just got to go fast
time burners oh no that's not a time
burner that's a bad move could I hang on
to this uh there at the very least
they're getting a draw
ah drawback to tournament oh I should
add that ah beautiful for that would
have been wonderful
is this the leader no it's not that's
not man now I'm already you know what
I'm thinking about already I'm thinking
about am I even gonna get in confetti
land that's the big question
forget about first place forget about
first place let me could you even get in
top three it's the big question alright
let's let's do what let's get to c5 it's
a nice square the Knights pinned ah man
I should have had that should I have I
could take that pawn take him now that
Knights pinned okay now I have a queen
oh let's get that night back okay I have
him back my bishop right here throw
these ponds up I gotta win fast oh that
would have been a bad pre-move back to
tournament goo 2 2 2 206 205 this is
close three guys up here less than six
minutes
the couple losses two losses but there's
been a couple quick designers okay I'll
throw the snake right at white going for
the snake variation all right not quite
not the exact variation that rook is
gone and now so too is the Queen I'm up
a rook I hear attack that pond here no
matter what
tricky discoveries fork oh now I'm
seeing Forks works that works now you're
seeing Forks stop that night just take
him out he's way too tricky way too
tricky watch out for stalemates push the
pond
here no matter what
here here and then throw their book in
the corner and that should be it back to
turn to 26 242 if we get paired up
that's a big game I could catch that guy
if we're paired up Paris up 440 okay
come on could I get h 7 maybe maybe
could happen
I'm quite am I trying too hard I think
I'm trying too hard
get my night here open up the H file
they're getting with the Queen maybe got
the H file focus on that pond get my
Bishop on a nice diagonal where's a nice
dog and I'll keep this guy sitting
queenside castle soon got that covered
night here is you're being watched over
sure what that's doing pawn push
shutdown that Bishop this Bishop needs
to be kicked out for this diagonal but
she goes back the Knights tied down to
the defense of that Bishop what I just
double up keep it closed over here this
diagonals opened up their night is still
tied down it's a very awkward situation
up there in let's let's do this get some
material over here give a check the King
moves got the Queen okay I'm Oh
my opponents down bout time I'm thinking
I'm down on time they're down on time
where's the mate don't run away oh my
goodness they resigned back to chairman
to 262 246 I gotta catch that guy we
need to be paired up to 62 we're gonna
be here paired up no Newman Newman gotta
play against Newman again oh is it gonna
be a quick win he's at negative 57 this
might be exactly what I need it Newman
is coming through for Jerry no way
Oh hee Joo Koon he Juke me ah Newman
Newman Newman okay that's a Seinfeld
reference that Seinfeld reference who
knows about Seinfeld I didn't mean to do
that or that oh I should have taken that
night ah
get these get these lose me and there my
queen doesn't want to defend that pawn
and a bunch of trades it's happening
soon let's get my queen doing something
else
I mean trade and then I could track down
this pawn I want to get my Queen to f4
if the Queen Queen trade is avoided okay
pressure here c3 I still put pressure on
it let's see five break down this
structure mmm
I guess oh my goodness that thing keeps
coming up
King position I should have been over
here soon let's get my pawn up here
first so that when I grab one of these
ponds it's very fast yeah and see what
they're gonna do that move alright let's
kind of dance a little bit all right my
wreck is gonna go pacman mode and
engaged
pac-man mode enabled here
keep running Jack that rook sneak up
have another pawn back to turn with her
down on time to 282 to 66 come on pair
me up one-one minute can I get this game
in berry-berry he turns the farm at me
the kitchen sink this is kitchen sink
Barry I could've just no you know I'm
the bishop take this I'm on the bishop
quick win I need a quick win I can have
a clean trade pawn push where they gonna
do I'm on the Queen meeting to maybe
here check if the King moves it's me
it's gonna be me if the King moves just
move baby sign back to 286 do you do
call it
come on call it call it call it quick
quick just call it come on I gotta go
for a scholar or not a scholars me yeah
actually a scholars me come on just call
the tournament blow the whistle on this
thing they resigned ah that's it 306
ah man or is somebody else gonna get a
win it says it's completed it says it's
completed how can I get first place did
I get first how can you get first yes oh
man that was with two losses in a drama
that shouldn't happen like that [ __ ] man
that could Fetty that confetti there
were a lot of games in there a lot of
quick resign errs ah man
final was 306 282 261 even that last one
wouldn't have mattered that last game
against Bari was enough all righty let's
close out of this
you